Utah's Davis School District has just
banned the LA the Bible rather from its
libraries and classrooms for vulgarity
and violence
this is this is really clever the school
district said that the Bible could be
considered pornographic this after a
parent filed a complaint and so
Elementary Middle School students in
Utah's Davis School District north of
Salt Lake City will no longer be able to
find the Bible at school libraries now
of course the Bible already could not be
taught in schools because some liberals
on the Supreme Court just decided that
out of thin air in the middle of the
20th century now it won't even be found
in the libraries the book will remain in
circulation quote only at the high
school level based on
age-appropriateness due to vulgarity or
violence that according to school
district spokesman Christopher Williams
and NBC News why now the parent is
filing the complaint because this parent
is upset that conservatives are Banning
actual gay porn